we start tonight president sippy cup
your president joe biden
probably resting comfortably after his
big summit with vladimir
as predicted by any objective measure
the meeting was an utter train wreck
putin basically gave joe nothing the
united
states nothing he made not a single
concession
there were zero agreements and after the
meeting putin held a solo press
conference
where let's see he mocked and trashed
the u.s
at length then biden gave a short
scripted speech probably written before
the summit
took a handful of questions from all as
always pre-selected reporters
and then got very cranky and lashed out
at reporters
which tends to happen when you don't get
your warm milky even stephen colbert
radical that he is brutally mocking
grandpa
joe last night but don't worry because
joe proudly announced that he
presented putin with a list of 16. now
pay attention here this is important 16
critical areas
of american infrastructure that vladimir
and the russians better not target with
a cyber attack that includes
telecommunications healthcare food
and energy okay first point how dumb is
it to give
a hostile actor an evil guy like
vladimir putin
16 specific things a road map that would
[ __ ]
the usa that's pretty dumb second
russia has already launched just in
recent weeks not one
but two cyber attacks against our energy
sector and our food sector
and biden he didn't respond in any way
so
question what would stop putin from
going after the other 14 sectors
and third all cyber attacks against
america and americans
uh joe that already should be off limits
you should have lectured him loudly
there should be consequences
not waivers to build pipelines really
really dumb
even for biden but as per usual the mob
the media
they're trying so hard to keep the biden
protection program going
although we go starting to see cracks
here and there
uh even late night comics are beginning
to realize this guy is not really
with us is he new york times reporting
after meeting putin
a biden trait shows itself again
stubborn
optimism and look at this from the
washington post
biden wiped the smirk off putin's face
yeah okay of course the high praise
continued
on fake news tv networks all around the
country take a look
i can't think of a more successful
diplomatic
trip in the 21st century than this one
my insight watching the press conference
yesterday was
there was a kind of poetry in his prose
i think that
this contrast that we saw today between
president trump and president biden
is an attempt for the administration to
say look we are now we are the adults in
the room and i think that joe biden is
the man of the moment
and yes he turned on caitlyn collins
fine
for a moment and then he apologized he's
such a nice guy he apologized did you
ever once hear trump apologize to a
reporter it's just an interesting
posture i viewed it at one point i wrote
professor biden because i thought
he was trying to basically be above it
be above the meeting
and explain look guys he's playing a
game
i'm having a really hard time not
reaching to my left picking up
this trash barrel right here and puking
in it
fox news cnn's jeff zeleny continued the
pravda style praise on twitter writing
quote
joe biden carried himself with a
seasoned air of confidence that new
president seldom possess
on-air cnn reporter had a rare moment of
honesty though however because he did go
after caitlyn collins she's very mean to
her
take a look we've not seen him do
is answer questions like that without
his aides
screaming at him to stop i have never
seen a president covering the last four
of them
who is so protected by his aides in
terms of uh often not wanting him to
answer some questions they were silent
today
jeff take it to the next level why are
they controlling him
i'm going to get in trouble if i take
another question i can't take another
question
why because his own staff knows
he's not capable of giving a coherent
answer
anyone with common sense knows what's
going on here joe biden gets agitated at
the drop of a hat
he gets cranky without his warm milky
and a sippy cup
frequently forgets what he's saying
mid-sentence at times he seems totally
lost dazed and confused
and that's why sippy cup staff prevents
him from answering too many questions
because they hate cleaning up the mess
that he makes
and tonight our country needs a capable
leader not a
mumbling bumbling idiot america is
facing serious problems a crisis
at our southern border it's real the
rising threat of china iran
russia war in the middle east spiking
inflation
by the way rightly so 70 percent of
americans think biden's policies are
making it worse
and of course inflation is not well a
concern for the big guy
because the biden family syndicate
business that's booming
zero experience hunter is now an artiste
and despite no formal training no degree
no experience no talent even
hunter's paintings are expected to fetch
up to 500 thousand dollars a piece
i don't know maybe we'll call it
portraits of a crackhead
turn political influence peddling now
the buyers will remain anonymous of
course
they've got to keep up this pay-to-play
scheme they've got going
hunter once again is selling access just
like he did with ukraine and barista
holdings with no experience
just like the 1.5 billion dollar deal
with the bank of china
the hundred thousand dollar shopping
spree how many of us get a hundred
thousand dollar shopping spree
with a chinese national and don't forget
the money from russia three and a half
million dollars
with the russian oligarch former first
lady of moscow
then there's the kazakh oligarchs that
he got money from
joe biden just claimed that ukraine now
think about this is too corrupt to be a
nato
but apparently not corrupt for his son
to do business
and make millions with ukraine or for
him
to demand that they fire a prosecutor or
they're not getting
our tax dollars wow that whole thing
seems corrupt
no legitimate person no entity would
ever pay hunter biden
a single penny for his expertise in
anything
his art i'm sure is not that good hunter
is a longtime degenerate crack addict
banned from a southern california hotel
why smoking crack
allegedly kicked out of a dc strip club
it's kind of hard i would imagine to get
kicked out of a strip club i'm just
guessing i don't go
for what oh smoking crack again
according to the daily mail he
repeatedly called
his white lawyer the n word imagine if
don jr or eric trump did that
other texts showing hunter using other
racial slurs
against asian americans recently died
denied at first
uh and then tried to abandon his newborn
child
then he did something really incredible
he kicked the mother
of his child off of her health insurance
shortly
after the child was born joey's pride
and joy hunter
and by the way hunter also reportedly oh
yeah he lied on his gun application
that would be called the felony then
later he took the firearm
and ditched it in a dumpster thank god a
responsible citizen found it
hunter biden is seriously troubled but
that never stopped his father
joe biden from using his son to fill the
biden syndicate family coffers
and of course joe biden denies this on
multiple occasions joe biden claimed
never not one time ever did he speak to
hunter biden
zero experience hunter about his foreign
business dealings not
once he said take a look vice president
how many times
have you ever spoken to your son about
his overseas business dealings
i've never spoken my son about his
overseas ministers i have never
discussed with my son or my brother or
anyone else
anything having to do with their
businesses period do you stand by your
statement that you did not discuss
any of your son's overseas business
never not once well joe biden now we
know is lying
a picture has emerged in the last two
weeks and a
picture speaks a thousand words this
picture
shows joe and hunter together with
hunter's
foreign business dealing from kazakhstan
they gave hunter money too multiple
pictures
eyewitness accounts troves of emails and
texts
from hunter's laptop revealed that the
big guy joe
was an integral part of hunter's
business activities
while he was vice president highly
unethically
unethical definitely corrupt and now the
important part
that actually compromises our country it
puts our country at risk
at the very least the appearance of
impropriety
is through the roof we all know that the
media would treat this differently if it
was a trump
and by the way a good decent human being
would not exploit
his troubled son for his own financial
gain how serious
is it hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it
anywhere else